Mike Florio joins us on loan from pro
football talk live on NBCSN course NBC
football night in America insider pro
football live on NBC sports radio
weekday 6:00 until 9:00 Eastern Mike can
you assess what the Rams have done here
in the last couple of weeks and how that
sort of does it present them differently
how much differently going into the
season well I think Wade Phillips the
defensive coordinator has his
fingerprints all over these moves in his
book that was published last year son of
bum he at one point mentions that he
believes he'd be a pretty good evaluator
of personnel and I think that Sean
McVeigh the head coach who has turned
over the defense to Wade Phillips has
let Wade Phillips look at the guys they
have and decide what do I need to do to
make this into a championship caliber
defense so pick up a couple of top shelf
corners and Marcus Peters and Aqib Talib
say goodbye to a guy like Robert Quinn a
good pass rusher not group Alec Ogletree
a very good middle linebacker but the
thinking I believe and this is all being
driven I believe by Wade Phillips let's
make that secondary better
let's have Aaron Donald create a lot of
havoc in the middle and he's eventually
going to get paid a lot of money to
continue doing that and that's the way
you build the defense that's going to
complement that offense so I think this
is Wade Phillips quasi general manager
of the Rams saying these are the guys I
need to get the defense to wear I think
it needs to be how big of an overhaul
are we going to see in Seattle well you
know it started with the coaching staff
right they basically fired everybody
except Pete Carroll on the coaching
staff and you could look at it and say
well does that necessarily mean they're
going to overhaul the roster as well if
the coaching staffs the problem well it
sure looks like they're going to Richard
Sherman likely out today Michael Bennett
already gone Earl Thomas available in
trade I feel like then what they're
doing now is they're they're taking
advantage of the fact that they finally
had a non playoff season they went five
straight years in the postseason I got
to the final eight each of those five
years and they were 9 and 7 but they
didn't make it and I think that's an
opportunity to rip off a couple of
band-aids they've done it with the
coaching staff they're doing it with the
roster I think we're going to see that
roster swing toward more offensive than
defensive building around a franchise
quarterback who still smack dab in the
middle of his prime Russell Wilson told
me during the season he wants to
the Tom Brady and make it 245 so that's
the guy you build around and now you use
the draft to go out and find your next
camp can swear who was a sixth-round
pick your next Richard Sherman who was a
fifth round pick and the next time the
team gets to a championship level you
got to pay some guys but then at some
point you move on from those guys and I
think that's the cycle of having a
franchise quarterback you build out
around him you make changes as you need
to but you're confident you're always
going to be competitive because you have
a quarterback who's a difference maker
did any questions or the question get
answered of what the Browns will do
following the combine no no I mean they
can do look how can you not take a
quarterback with the first overall pick
now if they pounce on a free agent like
AJ McCarron and Peter King had the
report this week that that's who Hugh
Jackson still wants if they give
McCarran a real contract it makes it
clear he's the starter and not just this
year's Mike Glennon who gets supplanted
by the number one overall pick in a
month and a half how can they not take a
quarterback they passed on Carson Wentz
two years ago they passed on to Shaun
Watson last year there's five guys and
who knows which of the five is going to
be the best but if you don't take a
quarterback at one you're passing on
maybe one or two of them before you come
back around again at four I don't know
how you don't take a quarterback with
the first overall pick I know that's a
qualm barkley steam is out there but
running back is a position where guys
get injured all the time you're going to
put all your eggs in that basket that
he's potentially going to be injury
prone and you're not going to know he's
injury prone until he gets to the NFL
level
I just think quarterback makes the most
sense but this year there really isn't
that guy who stands out it's five
different guys and it all depends on who
they really like but but I think that
they have to take seriously the prospect
of using that first overall pick on a
quarterback and finally getting a guy
who can be their quarterback for years
to come Peter King was on the show
recently this was a Tuesday and this is
what he had to say this was in regards
to Josh Rosen at UCLA to me the NFL has
an inherent distrust of rich kids they
just do and you have to prove to them
that being rich doesn't matter
Josh Rosen's family is wealthy his great
grandmother
did the Wharton School at Penn his
father is a very successful surgeon in
Los Angeles they've got a lot of money
so you know so a lot of people in the
NFL just sort of roll their eyes at that
to begin with what do you make of that
Mike should Peyton Manning and Eli
Manning have not been drafted I have a
feeling that Archie saved some of his
football money III I think that that can
be a factor because I think what the NFL
wants is players who are completely and
totally all-in because this is it this
is their ticket out of poverty this is
their ticket out of either working in a
coal mine or working in a steel mill
which i think is one of the big reasons
why so many great football players came
out of western Pennsylvania because I'm
gonna go all-in with football cuz I
don't want to go 3,000 feet underground
so I I understand that there would be
hesitation but I don't know how big of a
factor it is because if you're a good
player you're a good player regardless
of of whether you come from financial
means or not but it's just one of the I
can't say it's not a factor but I don't
think it should be an overriding factor
for any player the combine questions for
Darius guys we're the LSU running back
and he said that he was asked if he
liked men and basically is your mom a
prostitute here where does this story go
from here well here's where it goes
probably nowhere because what the NFL
typically does and we've seen this three
times now in five years Nick kasih in
2013 Eli Apple in 2016 darius guys now
the NFL issues the statement it's
inappropriate it's unacceptable we'll
look into it and then nothing ever
happens nothing ever changes and the
Falcons were the team that asked Eli
Apple the question do you like men two
years ago and they were disciplined in
that they were trained they were talked
to they didn't have any tangible
consequence so there's if there isn't
gonna be punishment and Tamura Smith
suggested yesterday on pft live band the
team from the combine next year now the
NFL is never going to go that far but if
you threaten to take away picks if you
take away a fifth round pick if a team
does that you're gonna see an end to
this so the NFL says all the right
things when it happens but the NFL has
yet to do anything necessary to deter
teams from doing it in the future that's
the challenge for the NFL
real punishment require them to record
every interaction with every one of
these players at the Senior Bowl at the
combine private workouts meetings at the
team facility they tape every practice
already they can tape these interactions
it's available to be checked and if
there's any crossing of the line then
there's real consequence and I think
taking away draft picks is the way to
get team's attention thank you Mike have
a great weekend talk soon Dan let Mike
Florio pro football talk on NBCSN
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]